it was harry and megan's final
engagement the body language showed that
relations were strained
now this new book shows just how
seriously things had broken down within
the royal family
the commonwealth day service seen as the
most public snub
it should have been the one public
moment where the royal family put their
arms around the couple for a show of
support
a source close to harry and megan said
they purposefully chose not to put them
in the procession
and not to be welcoming it was most
unpleasant
the book talks of the infighting
suspicion and vipers within the palace
that made the sussexes feel they had to
step away
with claims they even considered
breaking protocol and making a surprise
visit to the queen
when they flew back for this engagement
the authors write
harry and megan however felt they've
been patronized by other family and
staff members for too long
the media speculated that megan was
behind the decision for the couple to
step back
but few knew how much she'd sacrificed
to try to make it work
as megan tearfully told a friend in
march i gave up my
entire life for this family i was
willing to do whatever it takes
but here we are it's very sad in january
harry unexpectedly spoke of his
frustrations
our hope was to continue serving the
queen the commonwealth
and my military associations but without
public funding unfortunately
that wasn't possible but this book goes
much further
certainly there will be people who are
hoping that this book may shed more
light on things that people perhaps have
felt have been
misreported or misunderstood there are
other people who may say that this is
very much their perspective and that we
potentially aren't getting the whole
picture because perhaps
other members of the royal family other
people have not
been heard in the same way the
publishers say it was written with
unique access with the participation of
those closest to the couple
but a spokesperson says that harry and
megan didn't give an interview
it does show a couple who felt they were
the star attraction
constrained by an institution greater
than them and that sense of bitterness
and resentment will be difficult reading
for the royal family